maintenant en fin de journée lisons les
ambitions de vladimir poutine qui
appelle donc l'armée ukrainienne à
prendre le pouvoir à kiev clovis casali
on vous retrouve c'est notre envoyé
spécial dans la capitale la nuit
commence à tomber sur place est-ce que
les bombardements se poursuivent dit
tout ce qu'il se passe
eh bien il ya quelques minutes il y à
une nouvelle détonation et elles sont
très régulières ces détonations ici à
kiev toute la journée avec les sirènes
qui retentissent appelant la population
à se rendre dans les abris des abris
sous les immeubles ou dans les stations
de métro donc des détonations et des
explosions un peu partout qu'on entend
les informations qu'on a ici c'est que
les combats se serait arrêté dans le
district doblones qui est seulement à
sept kilomètres d'où on se trouve donc
c'est vraiment considérée comme une
partie à part entière de kiev ce
quartier de au blosne on a parlé avec
des ukrainiens le ppe-de ukrainien qu'on
voit dans les rues qui sortent entre
deux sirènes quand ils jugent le moment
opportun
et quand ils se comptent ils ont
l'impression qu'ils sont en sécurité on
a rencontré par exemple deux vieilles
dames qui sortait quelques minutes et
qui nous disaient elles n'ont pas peur
mais elles en veulent à vladimir poutine
elles ont des amis en russie elles ne
comprennent pas pourquoi la russie
attaque l'ukraine de la sorte en tout
cas de la tension quand même ici il faut
savoir aussi que beaucoup du craignant
déjà quitté kiev ont pris la route pour
aller davantage à l'ouest où il pensait
qu'il serait en sécurité
la situation ici en tout cas est assez
volatile on ne sait pas exactement
où en sont les combats on entend des
détonations on entend des explosions et
la crainte bien évidemment c'est de voir
les russes arrivés ici dans le centre
ville
clovis la capitale est passé en phase
défensive dit le maire de la ville ça
veut dire que les ukrainiens sont
appelés à défendre leur capitale est-ce
que
vous le constatez est ce qu'il y à des
ukrainiens qui veulent en découdre où
les rues sont complètement vide comme on
le voit derrière vous
alors les rues wii sont vides mais
autour de nous dans d'autres rues et
bien il y à des blindés ukrainien on a
vu aussi des hommes qui mettent leur
gilet pare-balles qu'ils l'enlèvent de
temps en temps au gré des sirènes au gré
des alertes on entend aussi très
régulièrement des ambulances passé en ce
qui concerne les ukrainiens qui
prendraient les armes c'est l'appel bien
sûr du président hélène ski du président
ukrainien et de tout le gouvernement
ukrainien et bien je peux vous dire que
aujourd'hui on a croisé une patrouille
de volontaires des hommes qui clairement
n'étaient pas des soldats russes mais
plutôt des soldats ukrainien pardon mais
plutôt à des miliciens ces volontaires
qui ont pris les armes spontanément et
qui avaient des habits militaires pour
certains pas pour d'autres les
ukrainiens en tout cas qui nous parlons
les jeunes et aussi un peu les moins
jeunes vous disent qu'ils sont prêts à
se battre pour défendre la capitale en
tout cas ceux qui ont décidé de rester
ici ils sont prêts à se battre alors que
vous l'avez dit et bien vladimir poutine
a appelé l'armée a renversé le président
azzedine ski qualifié de drogués de néo
nazis alors que le pouvoir ukrainien lui
accuse poutine d'opérer une invasion
tels les nazis durant la seconde guerre
mondiale et donc vladimir poutine
clairement essaye de diviser qui avait
essayé de diviser l'armée en appelant à
ce renversement du pouvoir pour pourquoi
pas mettre en place quelqu'un qui serait
pro moscou est probable a dit marc
poutine
merci beaucoup clovis casali envoyé
spécial france 24 dans cette capitale
kiev